is fighting
dude's fighting is that a hot is that
hot or not
i love the complete pillar i want to
watch a man fold laundry
okay
go ahead i don't mind watching a guy
fight but like i don't think i could
date a boxer like my nerves listen i
can't handle seeing you in the ring
fighting like i i can't i can't as my
man i can't you would freak out i would
freak out of course
you're not gonna do stand by your man
you're like you're not fighting i mean i
just don't think i would date a boxer
yeah
i i can't that lifestyle oh my god but
when he wins and he's like just [ __ ]
fist pumping on on top of the ring and i
love that but my nerves like i'm too
much of a nervous freak with that stuff
that i don't want to see my man getting
punched in the face or somebody punching
are you the type of girl that would lose
it would like jump in the ring and
that's what i'm saying like defend her
man that's what i mean like i want to be
an assistant teddy is getting worked up
right now
that's what i mean so imagine me
actually seeing my man fight i would be
like no i would jump in the ring and do
but it's more of a turn-on
uh
for you see a guy like
folding laundry
doing the dishes
just being like softer in general
playing with dogs playing with kids
that's a turn-on for you yes
like men showing like you love what
seeing a guy with kids i gotta adopt
some kids guys i don't know
no it could be with your nephews oh you
have it yeah i might not you gotta hang
out with your nephew yeah every guy
in here right now
um anyway so
we're learning some things about our
friends here amber and jenny she's more
into the bad boys she's more into the
guys that fold laundry
you know that's just how it is good to
know so the the paul brothers uh be on
standby
[Music]
you